what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
um today I am going to be applying for a
job so the YouTube views have been low
you know just been going broke out here
I've been hearing all the internet
talking
um and so I decided to buckle up my
bootstraps and apply for a job so today
I'm going to be applying for a body
positive role
um it's a body positive social media
intern I do know a thing or two about
social media so I will be applying for
this job Hi how are you
I'm good how are you I'm good
nice to meet you I'm I'm the director
um
um and I believe it was your assistant
who reached out um saying that you were
interested
um I
kind of wanted to ask you a couple
questions and get to know you a little
bit better better and like to see if
you're a good fit for this position
um so yeah this shouldn't take too long
um so yeah do you have any questions for
me before we get started or no I was I
was told it's like a social media
internship this is what I was told so I
wanted to learn a little bit more about
the role
yeah so um but I just want to make clear
I did mention this to your assistant but
it is a volunteer position
um so if you're looking for something
um paid then you know that's not
something that we can offer this time to
sort of small okay but I get like
working
experience out of it right
yeah okay cool
um so I guess the first thing I kind of
wanted to ask was I want you to tell me
a little bit about yourself
yeah um so I I work
in social media and I've done that for
about a year and a half before that I
worked in sales
um and in sales I sold copiers so that's
what I do
okay so yeah you have a marketing
background a social media background
yeah
um so I kind of asked why did you apply
for this position why is you know our
cause or our mission important to you
yeah
um the body because it was body positive
right
yeah so I was thinking body positive
the best way we could be body positive
was to help people lose weight so I'm a
personal trainer I'm certified so I was
like I could really help people lose
weight yes
uh
um
I think there's the we have a different
perspective of body positivity
um than you might which I respect you
know your kind of perspective
um of course like
um there's a lot of varying ways that
people look at it and different things
work for different people
um and you know from our like our
organization experience and
organization's view we believe that body
positivity is more encouraging people to
um kind of appreciate themselves and be
able to live in the body that they're in
um but of course like a lot of that
doesn't mean that people that you know
want to lose weight or something like
that just be shamed or anything like
that
um so yeah but
um I guess maybe this is a little bit
all right sorry I couldn't do the
nutrition and like the way we could like
be comfortable and lose weight that's
what I was thinking so I was thinking
like you know I have the social media
experience I just feel like I could take
this page to new heights
um
um is this like a joke or something I am
did I stutter
um
that's I I think that that's like a
great uh
like view that you have for something
that you want to do personally but for
our organization that's just not our you
know our values or what we're um it's
it's state it's stay fat
um
I'm sorry what
no I'm just asking it's stay fat don't
improve
well we don't we don't view fat as
something negative right something that
needs to be improved
um and again like I I'm saying I respect
your perspective
um and I don't think they're making me
like to be argued about on that end
because like everyone has different life
experiences and for some people you know
embracing body positivity has been
important for their mental and their
physical health and for other people you
know they've taken different routes and
that's totally fine
um
outside of the organization okay yeah I
don't have to post about weight loss I
was I was just thinking to be like a new
angle to like take the page to new
levels you know
yeah so there's just like you know
um kind of like we have a set value
um and just a mission especially since
we're a body positive Alliance I feel
like
um that might kind of go against our
audience and what our audience looks for
and also like what our goal is
um so but you know um oh okay thank you
for applying I guess
um I um what I get eliminated already
no already
because I want to add the nutrition in
that's I mean look here's the thing
right
um I want you to know that like personal
opinions should not be you know taken
into consideration when it comes to
um these kinds of positions right
personally I don't believe that any
obviously there's like you know our
political spectrum and a lot of times
people will get eliminated from certain
jobs and things like that because they
don't lean up okay or something like
that and that's obviously
um not right at all um but it's just
that this organization's goal is like
one certain thing if it was you know
it's something else
um I mean I want to ask you are are you
willing to kind of create content for us
that aligns with our values that doesn't
talk about you know we're quite lost or
um yeah yeah I mean I'm all for people
being or something like I'm all for
people being like comfortable and
confident
but I do think the best way is to
confidently lose weight and get in good
shape and you'll be happy and healthy
however I can put these aside for this
role
um
okay I I guess we can kind of like move
on with the interview and I can just ask
you some more questions
okay a little bit more
um I we do like I don't want to practice
by saying that we do prefer people so
you know be passionate for the cause so
that they can you know you know come up
with content ideas because as social
media managers you would have to come up
with you know ideas for content
um but I understand
your view on this and I feel like it
might be difficult to come up with
content ideas if it's not something that
you're a particularly passionate about
or that useful I think I could come up
with some content ideas
um what guess what what what does like
body liberation mean to you or what does
you know
um I guess what would you think would be
some content ideas for a body positive
okay body Liberation is to me to me it's
liberating Your Body by being able to
move I was a former fatty okay I was a
former fatty I was very fat and I I used
to um have all these like people telling
me
just stay fat you're okay but what
really liberated me was getting on the
treadmill and I ran him whole Marathon
so you know I guess what I could do is
like
the best I think the best piece of
content is
five ways to get on the treadmill maybe
not lose weight but move your body
and then number one would be treadmill
number two would be bike number three
would be rollerblades four would be
scooter and five hmm what could five be
see this is on the spot this is off the
Dome
um
okay
I just want to confirm because I feel
like this might be a joke or something I
wouldn't do you like that
I thought I was applying for a an
internship no I don't know yeah I just
it's just I feel like when people apply
to a role they kind of look into the
organization that they're applying to
and I feel like maybe you would have
seen that weird I thought oh I felt like
I was the one to show you guys the light
yes because as a former fatty I'm like
the perfect person I'm like let's take
this page to new heights
I really like I really I know I keep
saying this but I really want to say I
respect your opinion and your life
experiences have cost you a highly
different view
um and my own life experiences and the
life experiences of the individual that
created this organization and the people
that work on it have been different
right um and so everyone kind of
develops different perspectives based on
what they believe
um and so again I understand like what
your perspective is it's just not
something that would work for our
organization and everyone advocates for
different things of course if there was
an organization that you know was
advocating for
um for example like uh recently the
Supreme Court broke down
um affirmative action so like students
for fair admissions they wouldn't want
someone working for them that strongly
believe that affirmative action is
amazing and great and beneficial
um right so that it would just be like
oh kind of I just I thought it isn't
against their mission see I thought we
would be in the same because like I
thought the body positive Movement Like
also encouraged healthy like they always
say we're encouraging healthy so I just
thought like me I could be the
encourager of healthy you know you could
still accept your body while we're like
being healthy so I thought yeah I
thought it would be a good fit
yeah um oh I have a better one I have a
better one outside of the country right
now so okay I was thinking I'm like five
ways to be confident while you lose
weight yes look I
um you know I you're you sound like a
great speaker and I think you really are
having fun with this interview but
um
are you not having fun
oh dang it I thought we were having so
much fun I I thought we were having the
best I mean I think this is definitely
the most interesting interview I've ever
done I'm here to convert you guys
into the treadmill you know what I mean
I started running yes
I'm a runner too like I I we should make
content together we can do like running
content look at this and we we already
collaborating
okay yeah but I did
I uh that our organization kind of like
Advocates more oh dang we don't want to
tell people to lose weight right if
that's something that makes me feel good
it makes me feel happy because I like it
I do it um but it's not something that
we want to tell people oh okay so if I
said oh what okay I can I can edit it so
it's like what if it makes you happy
here's five tips to lose weight by
running
if I added the if it makes you happy I
I think you're really misunderstanding
um our purpose I'm really I'm grateful
that you reached out
um and I'm glad that I got to know you a
little bit
um
and I don't I don't think maybe this
position is for you because I think
maybe you misunderstood kind of what we
mean by body positive I mean again you
might have a different outlook on that
and we respect that but I just thought
it was like we we encourage healthy
that's I always hear it so I just
thought ah dang
I guess not
okay well let me let me fix it what if I
what if I do what if I do stay fat
don't lose weight stay fat
that kind of that language is kind of oh
stay obese
stay plus size
stay curvy
which one
that's not the kind of content like
most more educational content and less
like
um kind of like
I guess what you call them like
affirmations
um so that was what I started with the
education of how to lose weight but it's
not that type of vegetation or not
there's lots of other places if people
want to lose weight we are not the
account for them anyways I really am I'm
trying to keep it as professional as
possible so I don't want to get into any
um like anything like that again I told
you as I said consistently I do respect
your opinion
um and I um and I'm not here to try to
change it or anything like that you
don't have to I'm not trying to change
your opinion I was just I'm applying for
the job you know I thought I was very
was I not professional I thought I was
very professional no no you you are it's
just that um and you are applying for
this position with a misunderstanding of
what our organization does
um and that and so that might make it
difficult but I'm not gonna say like
you're completely eliminated or anything
like that uh it's just it it it's really
difficult to consider you as an option
just because it's not this is not our
our our perspective body positivity and
not something that you're passionate
about and then I know you're talking
about oh no I'm very passionate about
body positivity I don't I don't think I
the positive ways to lose lose the flab
who are you looking at someone's is
someone someone they can come on the
screen too if they want they can join
the convo
um this is you know I'm part of this
organization it's my sister she's just
oh okay I can't hear anything so she's
just you know walked into the room but
um
uh I'm sorry what was I saying uh you
did talk about health and again I want
to just you know say that we kind of we
we do we'll prioritize Health but we
just don't believe that weight is you
know one of the best indicators of
Health
um you know I agree with you I agree
with you and I could totally go through
this because weight is totally not the
best indicator of Health what is is
waist to hip ratio so what we can do is
I can show them you know because they'll
be like you're not just a number and I
would agree you are not just a number
okay you know I've worked with people
that didn't lose any weight but are have
gone down three dress sizes so what I'll
do is I'll show them the visceral fat
yes
um I think you're on the same I think
we're on the same wavelength
I I don't think we are
um again look I I do have to I have
another meeting after this really I
thought I booked out a half hour no it
was only 15. you did you okay well you
did if you want to continue this for
another five minutes but I just oh okay
um yeah I would love to
oh
I'm not really sure this is an interview
it's more just like a conversation I
hope it's a respectful one I hope you
don't have a negative view body positive
movement even if you disagree with it um
I've always been someone that yeah I'm
part of it that we can reach a middle
ground I'm part of it
everything I've said is very body
positive
not I guess it's um not the type of body
positivity that we are in a different
type not the weight loss type just the
stay fat type
um
okay I
I don't know what to say because I feel
like you're really making it's kind of
difficult
um what am I doing am I I'm I'm so
friendly
I just did the language is not something
again like oh sorry sorry not fat um
blubbery no no no no no
um
thick we don't think is a negative a
negative word and it's kind of agreeing
it's like it's negative
um so no I wasn't I just don't like the
language because I feel like you're
going to be saying it like it's like a
negative thing no I was saying like what
it is like okay I was I was 200 and I
don't know 20 pounds that's pretty big
so because that I would I would have
described myself as fat now yeah I would
say not fat anymore
yeah and I agree with you right but that
being described as fat is not it's just
a descriptor right it's not a negative
right right and we don't have to make it
a negative thing and obviously I'm
you know
um
kind of I just wanted to kind of get to
know you better and this is an interview
and I feel like I'm not asking you any
questions
um so
um but go ahead I'm ready I I guess the
only thing we don't have much time but
um
I kind of feel like I already know the
answer to this question but I wanted to
ask what you know about our our
organization specifically well I saw
your page um and I was like they don't
post enough and then I was thinking I
heard that you guys are a body positive
organization I can't remember what
school it was I think it's with the
school am I right
maybe it's like working with the school
something I forget exactly we have we
have chapters at high schools and
college universities um but we're like
an independent like a non-profit like
yeah so what I was thinking was you guys
want to be body positive that's the
message you want to spend build
community and therefore what I was
thinking was I could build community
Again by helping fat chicks lose weight
yes as a former fat chick so I can't not
as an insult just a description
I do agree that we were not posting
enough
um but that was because we didn't have a
social media manager it's your lucky day
when it comes to what to uh what you're
saying about
encouraging people to lose weight that's
just not what we do like I need to be
clear about that it's not what we do
what about what okay you're right I
forgot wait wait isn't good what if we
just had moved encourage you to move
would that be good
but again we're not anyone's like we're
not here to be anyone's like doctor or
anything like that right we are just
here to kind of give people education on
you know
um what we want to advocate for you know
and it's not just body positivity when
it comes to you know body Liberation and
fat Liberation but also when it comes to
you know we have paper disability rights
and things like that
um those are just a lot of things that
we want to spread information and
awareness about
um and try to talk more about so that's
kind of what we want to do and it it
it's not weight loss oh
well
maybe moving maybe moving
um trying to think of some other words
so I don't understand like what type of
content do you guys like are you trying
to post if it's education like what are
we if it's not to lose weight like what
are we educating people on like we're
talking about um you know how for
example one thing that we thought about
in the past was like how the BMI scale
um is not a good indicator of Health
right or
um ways to hip ratio I got you guys that
is the best indicator of Health
we don't agree with that one either um
just because you know a lot of those
things are really skewed and every human
being is different we all have different
genetics we all have different bodies we
all have different things different you
know weights where we're healthy at um
and so that kind of very standardized
measures so it's you guys so it's you
guys posting that the BMI is bad that's
what we're well I'm just giving like an
education educating right
um sometimes we post like you know a lot
of our Graphics right now has been you
know different advertisements or
different events that we've been doing
things like that
um and you know obviously again like
educationally like in next month is
disability pride month so we're like I
think we're you know planning to you
know educate people on the Ada and
disability advocacy and things like that
so what about a running event
we could even add in like a wheelchair
run too if you want to add the disabled
people
are running like a 5k see look I'm
coming up with these ideas yeah I think
our I think our time is uh
um
um yeah we're a student organization
um and so we're just gonna we're trying
to
Advocate um for something that we're
passionate about and again I've said
this multiple times but I do respect you
like I'm not I I I and there's lots of
people in this world that you know um
have the same opinions as you do and
that's okay like we're we're not here to
change anyone's opinions we're just here
to
um kind of uh you know spread this kind
of awareness but there is some issue
with the way that the media portrays
bodies and there are issues the way that
you know fat people are treated and
there are things like that so that's all
well yeah and I have a solution lose
weight
that's just we don't believe that it's
harmful thing it works for me it worked
for me
and and I'm I'm glad it did but it it's
just not something oh okay we believe
it's gonna work a majority of people I
had I had a great time
um I think I'm a shoe-in for this
position honestly
um I think I'm a great fit
so you know I can start like next week
just so you know
um yeah I'll keep in touch
um I I feel like you're you're smart
enough to know where my
face is reading with this but
um your face is reading what
I am a Smart Cookie you know
yeah
I'm sure you are
um it was great to meet you and talk to
you
um even if there was it wasn't really an
interview but it was a intellectual
discussion maybe
um but I'm glad that
um
I could at least talk to you I think
that this position may not be for you no
no I'm the perfect fit I'm a perfect fit
look it I got I got all the five ways to
move
we could even do a shimmy like five ways
To Shimmy you know you know ten ways ten
I'm really glad you do but I just don't
add the person in charge of recruiting
um it's just not you know something that
I think would be a good fit for you you
know that aspect of being passionate
about body positivity
um is not there
um I do have to go but it was good it's
very nice to meet you and and I hope one
day you will kind of take more of a look
into our kind of work and just the body
Liberation movement in general and learn
a little bit more about it um and again
you don't have to change your opinion
but kind of get more information is
simply than just kind of believing that
we advocate for state that or something
like that well I was just going based
off of what there's a lot I was going
off of like what you were saying so that
that was why I said that it wasn't like
off of research it was just based off of
like what you were saying so that was
why yeah no I understand that I just
wanted to say you know a lot of times
it's good to look into you know what
someone on the opposite side thinks so
you can learn more about it and of
course like I you know try to research
what people
um well you could learn so much if I
worked there I could teach you so much I
thought I'm the one trying to work with
people that disagree you on the other
hand are saying no so I was like if
anything if anything I should say the
same thing
but you're not trying to work with
people that disagree you're trying to
put stuff that you agree with on an
outlet that doesn't agree with you well
I was thinking we could we could find
some Middle Ground
um you know I will keep in contact with
you if you are interested you can meet
with our executive director and I would
love to more I would love um I will put
me through you
um well they're obviously not here right
now
um but uh I'll I'll definitely reach
back out
um if you know after speaking with them
but yeah I have a meeting after this
okay have a good meeting very nice to
meet you I know I'm perfect for this job
yes all right thank you now I really
thought this interview was going quite
well I thought I was a shoe-in for the
position I mean I've given her some
ideas for Content I had a bunch of work
experience how could I not get the role
now surprisingly
it's been a couple days I have not heard
back from them
I am waiting for my job offer I'm ready
to start when when can I start
I guess I'll just have to keep on
applying let me know guys in the
comments where I should apply for a job
next
um you know I'm a hard-working
individual and the the YouTube streets
just haven't been great to me and now
I'm just looking for work so let me know
where you want to see me apply to next